il se pensait à l'abri des bombes
cloîtrée dans ce bâtiment la maison de
la culture de l'iscid chance qu a été
frappée ce vendredi par les forces
russes
quatre civils qui s'y étaient réfugiés
ont été tués
l'horreur sans par un peu plus de cette
ville proche de severodonec une zone clé
pour le contrôle du dombass devenu la
cible prioritaire des frappes russe
l'isie jones qu est défigurée beaucoup
d'habitants se résigne à quitter la
ville
c'était émouvant
j'ai la gorge serrée j'ai grandi ici il
ya des photos de moi quand j'avais 4 ans
sous ces arbres j'ai grandi ici c'est
dommage c'est difficile de parler j'ai
pleuré hier j'ai grandi
[Musique]
nous partons parce que c'est devenu et
frion nous laissons tous derrière nous
et nous partons parce que personne ne
survivraient à une telle attaque
dans la capitale kiev les combats qui
font rage dans le donbass occupe tous
les esprits selon les autorités entre
100 et 200 soldats du craignent un sont
tués chaque jour au front et ce samedi
les habitants de kiev sont venus rendre
un dernier hommage à l'un de leurs héros
romane rate chauny ce jeune activiste de
24 ans mort au combat était une figure
du mouvement maiden de 2014 il avait à
l'époque 16 ans était l'un des premiers
étudiants à manifester dans les rues de
kiev et à rêver d'une autre ukraine